hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are here with a
long awaited jujutsu kaisen video
because it's about time that we talk
about maki
and we'll just holy crap maki because i
just
incredible developments are happening
within the judicial manga and speaking
of we have some very very good news
because the series will be taken off
hiatus incredibly shortly so make sure
to subscribe to the new
review for a consistent injection of
cursed culture administered directly
into your youtube feed because i could
not be more hyped to dive back into this
particular series jujitsukai sen has
pretty consistently blown me away and
the most recent chapters only emphasize
that
in fact they may very well be some of
the best i've read despite their various
well their various production issues but
we will get to that because we have now
just embarked on something of a miniac
focusing solely on a secondary character
who has now managed to change the course
of
quite literally the entire series marky
is
honestly she was never any particular
highlight of judas kaisen for me
i mean i liked her and well she was
there and that's that's about it
which isn't to say that she was poorly
written or used or anything
i just think that the standard for
captivating characters in jujutsu kaisen
is so astonishingly high that
she never quite met that for me never
quite until now that is because that
has all changed and i should say the
same for mai as well i never
really cared for mai and now whenever i
think about her my heart well
it just breaks thanks to a couple of
drawings scattered across various pieces
of paper
known as manga because manga can be a
very powerful thing like that so let's
talk about these stunning developments
the premise of this arc is innocent
enough maki returns to the zenin clan
facility and then proceeds to brutally
slaughter everyone and everything in
sight in the methodology that i'm going
to describe is very similar to kill bill
volume 1.
and it's all just so gruesomely
satisfying to watch because the zening
clan really have been built up as a pack
of pretty blatant antagonists over the
course of jude's kaisen with some rebels
here and there like maki
mai and megumi they all start with them
actually huh that's a thing i've not
noticed until now but this arc is the
moment where we see how truly dark this
organization actually is with oogies and
in shira well she had disappointment in
his own children
culminating in deciding to just rid the
world of both of them and i will say
that if i did have one
criticism of this maniac it said ogie
does the very stereotypical
classic villain thing of leaving his
victims alone and just assuming that
they will die
instead of taking the opportunity to
just kill maki and mai himself it was a
stupid
stupid move but then again oogie is a
character blinded by his own arrogance
so
stupidity does make sense but this leads
us into the tragic yet beautiful moment
where mai ultimately sacrifices herself
for maki and some very interesting law
that cursed energy essentially treats
the concept of twins as one
individual and so neither maki nor maya
are technically a complete person on
their own in that regard hence why mai
gets a curse technique and maki is
saddled with her heavenly restriction
and in a rather touching moment on the
verge of death maki and mai
become complete resulting in the birth
of one of the most terrifying characters
that jujitsu kaisen has seen since toji
fushiguru and i love this new maki i
know she's technically on our side but
what follows is
pretty undeniably in the darker segment
of the good to evil spectrum
but i loved every second of it probably
my favorite encounter was maki's first
victim being her father oogie there's
this stunning kind of overblown full
page panel of oogie preparing his
ultimate serious business jujutsu thing
and akatami takes this opportunity to
emphasize the detail of his cursed
energy as well as the raw emotional
release of ogi
in this moment but then we immediately
cut to maki's attack and in contrast to
ogi's fiery detailed gigantic emotional
release
maki's attack is just a simple casual
swing of a sword it's very purposely
undramatic in nature which is
interesting because you would think that
this moment of maki
finally being able to take revenge is a
pretty big deal but instead maki is
actually treating this more like a pest
exterminator would she's on the job and
she's going to get it done quickly and
efficiently like this is just another
mundane day at work but as for what maki
has become let's dwell on this for a bit
because i don't think it's properly
understood by a lot of people perhaps
even
admittedly myself but well we'll see so
i got a lot of comments on my recent
special great sorceress video saying
stuff like who is maki and the reason
why i didn't include her as a potential
special grade is because i'm not sure if
she can actually be considered a
sorcerer at this point
originally marky did possess very very
low levels of cursed energy
not enough to be applied to any sort of
decent use but the trade-off for that
was her heavenly restriction which made
her a physical beast
i don't know why i separated the bee
from the east in that word but it
happened and i'm not re-recording it so
if i understand this correctly with mai
and maki being treated as one by their
well the general principles of cursed
energy the fact that mai does possess a
decent quantity of cursed energy
actively hindered maki's heavenly
restriction because injured kaisen much
like real life you only get what you pay
for so a character like toji fushigoro
paid the
full price of having zero cursed energy
and so he got the full product of
superhuman abilities meanwhile maki
and mai combined paid half price and so
maki was given a significantly
less powerful heavenly restriction
however in these recent chapters maya
did identify
this and so she removed her cursed
energy from existence
via the act of death i guess not removed
from existence because she did end up
crafting the cursed tool but now that
the twins have paid that full price of
cursed energy marky is able to receive
the full benefits of her heavenly
restriction which has essentially turned
her into what togi was there's even a
very direct comparison of the two of
them both literally and artistically
and as part of this i believe that what
little cursed energy monkey did possess
has also been extinguished and that is
very integral to this perfect toji
effect
essentially the most recent jujutsu
kaisen chapters have given birth to an
existence that could very much rival
toji
if not surpass him and even surpass some
of the greatest judo sorcerers in the
series
maki like i said is now an absolute
beast and i would genuinely fear for
anyone who has to go up against her and
i think it's even more insane that
akutami was able to pull this off so
successfully like i said maki to me
yeah look she was fine but she was never
the reason why i read or watched due to
skysense however these handful of
chapters feature her as the primary
protagonist of this miniak and maki
is shockingly captivating in that role
in a different world she could very much
shoulder her own entire manga series
much like many of the jujutsu kissing
characters could i mean for example i
could easily see gojo running his own
series or megami or utah
well i guess yuta actually did have his
own series but you get the point
and that's very much one of the
phenomenal core strengths of
jutsukai-san because akutami is able to
make every
character feel like the main character
of their own story within this one
greater story it's genuinely impressive
and this also doesn't come without an
unexpected twisty because probably my
favorite part of this entire maki
section is the brief focus on her mother
and it's very very brief so akitami very
sneakily leads us to believe that the
mother
keeps saying the mother does the mother
have a name right so he just looked it
up and the mother does not have her name
she is just
unnamed woman so uh that's interesting
but in any case we are led to believe
that unnamed mother shares the
philosophy of oogie with the whole
for once make me glad that i gave birth
to you lying but then we discover
at the end right after maki slices her
unnamed mother's
throat open that unnamed mother really
was proud of her daughters all along and
even
contributes to the zen in slaughter by
ensuring the death of narya so that was
another painful twist the idea that maki
will never actually know how much her
own mother loved both her
and mai and come to think that maybe
that's why she remains unnamed because
quite frankly the xenon name
it's a bit of a stain injured kaisen
because it's often used to denote
figures who are quite
dickish to say the least so perhaps not
identifying maki's mother is a way to
keep her sort of narratively separate
from this zenin stain or it might also
have been done on purpose to show maki's
complete and utter apathy towards her
mother like akutami saying to us
well maki doesn't care about her and
mother so well why should you but on the
other hand we are forced to care about
her father because he is one of the big
core problems so he gets identified as a
nasty nasty augustine in and then
promptly slaughtered going back to nelly
though having brought him up this was a
big surprise because i really did not
expect him to die anywhere near this
early i thought for sure that he was
going to be some sort of secondary
antagonist during the culling game but
you know hey i'll take that subversion
of expectations and it is actually kind
of nice to know that going forward
we won't have to deal with him what i'm
very much looking forward to though is
hearing fushiguro's reaction to all of
this
the zening clan is obviously pretty
intrinsically tied to his story
particularly since he is now the head of
set clan and just thinking about
the head of what exactly i guess what
two people at this point but it might be
a gigantic weight lifted from his
shoulders knowing that his family roots
are quashed and dealt with
in fact the significance of this handful
of chapters really cannot be understated
because maki went on to kill everyone
present at the zenin estate but then the
epilogue also goes on to confirm that
she continued her slaughter fest
afterwards
so much so that the gojo and the karma
clans even held a meeting to propose
removing the zenin family from the big
three structure altogether like this
is a major major power shift and it will
leave a vacuum
one that i'm not sure how it gets filled
or whether or not it even needs filling
jiu-jitsu kaisen obviously isn't
intended to run for all that much longer
in the grand scheme of things so maybe
it's just a matter of time before the
camo and gojo clans crumble before our
eyes as well
things are just moving so insanely fast
right now on judeskai sen
that i cannot wait for the next chapter
and yes we should also discuss
the various elephants in our various
rooms though being akutami's condition
not exactly sure what it is but it has
definitely impacted the series with
chapter 152 notably only containing nine
pages
so about half of the average chapter but
there were also points throughout this
miniak where akutami clearly either did
not have the time or the physical
ability to finish a chapter
and so these rough sketches were
published instead which is always sad to
see because an artist of akatami's
caliber really does deserve the full
benefit of complete work however that's
also the nature of the weekly manga
publishing grind for whatever health
reason akatami clearly fell behind in
terms of production
and in the end the decision was made for
the manga to go on hiatus which was
definitely for the best
because what we were reading here
towards the end was a bit of a sinking
ship of time and physical limitations
and jujitsukai sen deserves the full
benefit of being read in a more complete
format so i will happily wait however
long it takes for akitami to get back on
track although this hiatus does give me
some
gives me some hunter hunter ptsd mostly
because this is not the first time this
has occurred back in the shibuyak which
i wasn't even reading weekly there were
some clear production issues happening
around the climax because all of a
sudden we were interrupted by a couple
of biller chapters which were designed
to be drawn
and produced very easily in though of
being able to release a proper chapter
so i don't know the full story behind
why those came into existence but it is
slightly worrying so i just hope that
akutami is taking care of himself
and isn't being pushed to the point of
self-destruction but back to the actual
material itself maki is now a standout
character of jujutsukai sen for me when
i think about this series i see her
standing proudly alongside powerhouses
like megami gojo and yuta and it's such
a difficult phenomenon to describe but
there's this distinct feeling that maki
has been elevated from supporting
character
to a legitimate serious protagonist
someone who i would be more than happy
to follow the story of in though of say
yuji and given how rapidly everything
introduced kaisen
is changing i can't wait to see what
akutami does with everyone else as well
both panda and maki have now had some
pretty big moments of development and we
have a whole cast remaining who would
certainly like some of what they're
having plus a whole culling game to set
up and continue which
i'd completely forgotten about in this
whole zenon business because marky's arc
was already practically a culling game
in its own right meanwhile it would be
right for you to gain more entertainment
by clicking this here next video there's
always more to learn explore and
experience about this wonderful series
so i look forward to seeing you there